est ce que moi je me prépare à la
première vidéo qui l'humilie vraiment
devant l'entièreté de ma communauté
enfin autre que le cas y ajoutera
évidemment il n'y a pas si longtemps que
ça ya quelques mois j'avais fait des
casse têtes en vidéo c'était d'ailleurs
l'une des premières activités manuelles
qu'on avait fait de cette chaîne à
chaque noël on m'offre un casse tête à
chaque noël je dis merci en souriant
mais en vrai le gars me torture en
m'offrant ça j'ai un peu le même
problème avec les énigmes
il ya beaucoup de fois d'ailleurs à noël
mais noël sont pas ou faut que
j'arrête cette fête
j'ai fait beaucoup de repas de noël où
quelqu'un dans c'est une énigme des
vagues comment en arriver là on n'a pas
les mêmes repas de noël je viens de vous
le dire je vous donne un exemple d'une
énigme qui m'énerve
un agent soit par une fenêtre d'une
maison de cinq étages et il se fait
absolument pas mal comment at il fait
bah y'a juste 200 réponses possibles en
fait je hausse de ton c'est énervant ce
qu en 2014 je m'excuse voilà en fait le
truc qui m'énerve avec les énigmes c'est
que des fois le cercle de réflexion dans
lequel tu devrais être il est beaucoup
trop large il ya beaucoup trop de
possibilités là par exemple je peux dire
il a sauté dans un arbre et du coup il
est pas blessé c'est techniquement vrai
mais l'énigme
ce n'est pas la réponse qu'elle attend
non non la réponse qu'elle a tancé il a
sauté du premier étage alors celle là
elle est vraiment mauvaise mais on a
vraiment des styles est ok alors tout
comme les casse-têtes je prends le mal
par les cornes et je me lance
aujourd'hui pour résoudre les énigmes
les plus prisés et compliquée du web
d'après les sites sur lesquels se
trouvent site qui probablement dit ça
dans le but que si tu en fasses une ton
ego soit tellement flatter que tu
partages le site à tes amis dans
l'espoir qu'ils n'y arrivent pas et que
tu puisse leur dire ma fort que toi je
vous préviens je vais être de mauvaise
foi si vous n'aimez pas la mauvaise foi
partez ou alors rester et essayé d'aimer
c'est un argument commun dont la
mystérieuse cellule vide
andy est enfermé dans une cellule le sol
c'est de la terre et il n'y a qu'une
seule fenêtre la fenêtre est trop haute
pour lui pour l'atteindre le seul outil
qu'il ya dans la cellule c'est une pelle
il ne va pas être capable de se nourrir
ou de boire de l'eau donc il n'a que
deux jours pour s'échapper où il mourra
ndi ne peut pas creuser un tunnel parce
que ça lui prendra plus que deux jours
comment fait donc ndi pour s'échapper de
la cellule alors ils mangent les
mauvaises herbes qu'on voit clairement
sur cette image qui est une vraie photo
prise de la cellule dédie d'ailleurs du
coup il gagne quatre jours de vie en
plus sauf qu'il faut cinq jours pour
creuser le tunnel dont qui s'en sort où
il peut pas atteindre la fenêtre mes
emails appels entre les barreaux et plus
les barreaux comme ça et ensuite ils
coincent l'appel et s'en sert comme
savez bardot
traction pour claque et sortir c'est
l'un ou l'autre la réponse elle lui doit
utiliser la pelle pour faire un petit
pas de terre sous la fenêtre comme ça il
peut l'atteindre et s'échapper de la
cellule il y à des barons à cette
fenêtre énigmes de détectives que seuls
les plus intelligents pourront résoudre
ça je fais partie des indigents et vous
êtes une belle bande de ce l'amour à un
enterrement tiercé gueissaz une fillette
aux funérailles de sa mère elle
rencontre un gars sympa qu'elle
connaissait pas mais qui était aussi aux
funérailles et ils ont un petit coup de
foudre étant occupés aux funérailles
elle n'a pas eu le temps de lui demander
son numéro avant qu'il parte elle a
vraiment essayé de le retrouver mais
personne savait qu'il était ni comment
le contact et quelques jours plus tard
sa soeur décède et la police soupçonne
qu'il s'agisse d'un meurtre qui a tué sa
soeur mais y'a juste huit mille
possibilités
pourquoi je peux pas m'empêcher de me
dire ça qui a tué sa soeur mais j'en
sais rien moi qui ai tué sa soeur je
sais pas moi ok ce gars là c'était un
psychopathe
en vrai il a fait j'en ai eu un coup de
mou n'est pas du tout ils voulaient
juste l'a kidnappée puis l'a tué on
parle choses agréables c'est bien il se
parle je t'aime bien mais on est ma mère
est morte quand même donc quand même
c'est chaud il se parle plus parce
qu'ils sont occupés
il se retrouve un peu plus tard lors des
funérailles sauf qu'en fait ils ne se
retrouvent pas et oui le gars croient
qu'ils parlent à la même fille mais en
fait c'est la soeur jumelle de cette
fille
bref y semant un resto de resto 3 reste
aux api l'abus et du coup l'auteur est
dit mais merde qui donc a tué ma soeur
est ce que vous avez tout suivi
je suis inspecteur squeeze hockey
attention elle a tué sa soeur elle
espérait que si quelqu'un d'autres
meurent dans sa famille l'homme qu'elle
est vue à l'enterrement de sa mère
viennent aussi à l'enterrement de sa
soeur
un professeur de mythe a appelé ça
l'énigme la plus dure du monde surtout
la plus conne bordel de merde je rage à
un voleur sur la mer un navire japonais
quitte le port et se dirige vers le
large le capitaine est allé huile et
certaines parties du navire et enlever
sa bague pour qu'elle ne soit pas
endommagée il la laissa sur la table à
côté de sa couchette à ce retour elle
n'était plus là
selon lui trois membres d'équipage
pouvait être coupable le cuisinier a dit
elle est connue mais j'aime dit
un truc
j'étais dans la cuisine pour préparer à
dîner de ce soir l'ingénieur a déclaré
je travaillais dans la salle des
machines pour m'assurer que tout
fonctionnait bien le bas rhin a dit
j'étais sur le mât pour corriger le
drapeau parce que quelqu'un l'avait
attachée à l'envers par erreur le
capitaine et médiatement sus de qui il
s'agissait
comment
ok j'ai le capitaine il parle lui les
son avis ok il ya quoi lui les sur un
navire des machines évidemment une fois
qu'on a eu les les machines
elle marche nickel alors pourquoi
l'ingénieur dit je travaillais dans la
salle des machines pour m'assurer que
tout fonctionnait bien alors vous
capitaine vient tout juste de huiler les
machines
or lors sympathie pour moi je pense que
c'est le cuisiner je disais moi pourquoi
j'ai envie qu'ils prennent tarifs le
cuisinier dans cette histoire mais là
rien de rationnel c'est vraiment gratuit
c'était le mara il s'agit d'un navire
japonais et le drapeau japonais n'a pas
de sens particulier au nom en ont elles
étaient bien en ange et un objet line
l'énigme était pas mal où vous êtes à
l'agitée coup cette fois je vais peut
être qu'on croyez moi j'en ai marre de
m'humilier devant la communauté meurtre
à l'école c'est que des choses joyeuses
le premier jour d'école quelqu'un
assassiné un professeur d'histoire la
police soupçonne quatre personnes qu'il
y avait à l'école au moment des faits le
paysagiste a dit qu'il était à
l'extérieur pour tondre la pelouse le
professeur de mathématiques a dit qu'il
faisait un test de moitié d'année
l'entraîneur de basket ball a déclaré
qu'il exécutait des exercices
d'entraînement avec ses joueurs
la directrice a dit qu'elle était dans
son bureau après avoir donné leurs
alibis la police a immédiatement arrêter
le tueur qui a tué professeur d'histoire
et comment la police l'a t-elle dessus
la police est très forte en tout cas à
chaque fois dancing en fait faut pas se
présenter sur l'énoncé faut se
concentrer sur ce que chacun dit il
était à l'extérieur pour tondre la
pelouse
c'est le premier jour d'école
je pense que c'est lié au fait que c'est
le premier jour d'école au bâton mais
j'ai dit j'ai trouvé il fait un test de
mionnay on est le premier jour d'école
du contre l'euro ce matin tu es le
professeur d'histoire à bages là et les
potes essayez donc de résoudre ces
énigmes à ça vaut le coup d'essayer
c'est pas si simple
attends je me rends compte qu'en vrai
j'adore les énigmes ou les gens ont des
alibis harris et peut-être scellé seul
que j'avais raison
après sportif alors à céréales killers a
kidnappé cinq personnes différentes et
les à chacun assis face à un verre d'eau
et deux pilules il leur a dit à tous
d'avaler une des deux pilules en
précisant que l'une était empoisonnée et
l'autre inoffensive
le tueur en série s'engager avaler la
pilule que chaque victime navale est pas
malheureusement toutes les victimes ont
choisi la pilule empoisonnée et sont
mortes comment le tueur en série les at
il tous amenés à prendre la pilule
empoisonnée
voilà peut-être que je spécule mais je
trouve que les petites gélules comme ça
sont un peu plus rassurante que les
médicaments rond faut jamais dû rentrer
dans la police
ok j'ai dans les deux pilules
avec du poison à tueur c'est un bâtard
et l'antidote se trouvait dans l'eau
mais comme c'était une période où il
faisait très froid dehors et où l'eau
était vraiment un m'as pris fin tout le
monde buvait tout le temps beaucoup la
journée les gens à bout d'un an il
n'avait plus trop soif quoi donc les
victimes ont pris la pilule sans boire
l'eau au celle inverse les deux
pilules étaient inoffensives et le
poison se trouvait dans l'eau c'est ça
aucune des pilules net a empoisonné le
poison était dans l'eau au yes je suis
refait une journée romantique à un peu
positif
monsieur et madame clyde sont partis en
vacances dans les montagnes mais deux
jours plus tard c'est seul que monsieur
klein rentrer chez lui il se rend alors
au commissariat et déclare que madame
clyde et tombées de la montagne
et on est morte le jour suivant en
détective steven rend visite à monsieur
clyde et l'arrêtent pour le meurtre de
sa femme clyde avoue la vérité et
demande aux détectives comment il a su
qu'il était le meurtrier
steven répond qu'il a simplement appelé
l' agence de voyages pour leur demander
quelques informations qu'a donc dit la
personne de l' agence de voyages aux
détectives bon le bus qui les amène en
haut de la montagne
il bosse avec l'âge ans attend c'est le
pire démarrage
qu'est ce qu'il a pu dire ce
d'agents de voyages il a dit qu'il y
avait des promotions il lui a dit m
quand vous allez inspecteurs vote
rappelle tombe bien en ce moment on fait
des remises sur les voyages à la
montagne ça vous intéresse du coup
inspecteurs steven il dit cool
des propos il part à la montagne et il
s'aperçoit qu'il a tellement neigé que
même si tu tombes de la montagne a
tellement de poudreuse à l'arrivée que
tu peux pas mourir
il en conclut donc elle est morte
d'autres choses et que c'est son mari
qui est coupable
voilà
au nom si au bout le même quelle agence
de voyages lui aurait avoué que monsieur
klein a acheté deux billets aller et un
seul billet retour
bah si je peux me permettre c'est
précipiter non comme conclusion là haut
il a le droit de faire le beau gosse est
dû prendre son billet aller mais
peut-être qu'ils s'étaient mis d'accord
pour chacun paye son billet retour en
fait ça fait pas de lui un couffin ford
l1 c'est bien mignon tout ça mais bon
monsieur klein dit prends tarifs pour
rien et à côté ces pédophiles mais parce
que ça fait du cinéma arabe alors
grumman pas un hashtag je suis monsieur
clyde ok c'est la dernière les amis une
femme a été traduite en justice pour
avoir tué son mari pître 1 les gens
veulent pas faire autre chose que bute
et d'autres gens quoi danser et nîmes
c'est chiant elle a dit qu'elle n'était
pas coupable et qui lui manquait
beaucoup bon ok il te manque t sur qui
tu manques délibéré vase
au moment du verdict l'avocate de la
femme se lève et dit son mari était
simplement porté disparu il va passer
les portes de ce tribunal d'ici trente
secondes tout le jury regarde alors les
portes en attendant que le mari de cette
femme les franchissent l'avocat conclut
en disant si vous étiez si sûr qu'elle
ait tué son mari vous ne regarderez pas
ses portes
le jury a alors immédiatement rendu un
verdict de culpabilité charge et
d'avocats mais ça va pas la tête ou quoi
le jury a ensuite déclaré la femme
coupable pourquoi
non mes mecs c'est ridicule si tu as
vraiment pas tuer ton mari et qu'on te
dit qu'il va arriver dans le tribunal
d'ici trente secondes tu vas tu regardes
vers les portes et espère le voir et
dire en fait il a envie à temps
est ce que c'est ça c'est exactement ça
ok je sais vous savez ce que c'est c'est
cette énigme est les dix années pour
tous se comptent pas encore partagé le
site sur facebook là parce qu'ils ont
tout foirer les énigmes on leur met une
dernière en disant c'est la plus dure
c'est là si tu réussis vraiment partage
là parce que c'est hyper grave
stay sont prêts à tout pour ramener du
trafic sur leur site bordel ben on peut
lire j'ai assuré quoi qu'il en soit le
boss de la dgs y va dès maintenant venir
me remettre ma plaque
un jour ça a marché avec m gibbs en vrai
ça me fait toujours marrer shoot des
niveaux les gens réfléchissent à 4
dessus j'absorbe plus tes nombreux à
réfléchir dessus plus tu finis à côté de
la plaque en l'occurrence énigmes
étaient pas ou feint mais des fois il ya
des énigmes mon gars étaient vraiment
trois heures de suite envie de tout
casser siv en fout c'est horrible je
suis plutôt content de la prestation
ouais franchement je n'étais pas trop
mal et a quand même le drapeau japonais
j'ai quand même bien en travers j'ai
vraiment été très confuse en gestion
vous avez passé un bon moment et vous
avez été bon vous avez réussi à résoudre
certaines je vous dis c'est ciao
c'est chiant
[Musique]